vous cherchez quoi madame le concert de
renault non non il passe ici fontaine
saint michel
c'est la mère qui prend
la mère elle m'a pris
même souvient
à mardi
avec ces mecs là c'est c'est parce les
mythes les toits de voir ouais bah là je
suis aujourd'hui parce que
et j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé
beaucoup ça fait de la peine de le voir
un creux de la vague aujourd'hui coûte
malraux beaucoup de vent c'était
vraiment chichi giron les boues parce
que [ __ ] on pressent les astros ja
happ a expliqué parce que c'est trop
fort mais aussi tu penses que bruel lui
a piqué un peu tous ses fans t'as fait
ça s'est passé selon java comprendre
comment les geôles son cours a coûté ce
sont ce genre de musique il sa pétition
s'en foutent bruel croit prononcé par
album il en a vendu 8
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
76 c'est que moi j'ai un chien et ça
fout une hache et moi pour le vérifier
j'achète mes voyages allemand j'ai mis
ce foulard est pour toi à toi tout petit
ouais h toujours au dessus parce que ce
qu'il n'a plus voulu dit parce qu'il est
un travail que vous l'aimez beaucoup et
que vous allez acheter son prochain
album sais pas trop je suis toujours pas
convaincu que vous êtes le vrai chanter
un peu pour voir qu'est ce que vous les
joues sont à vous de choisir ça alors là
c'est pas l'homme qui prend la mer
c'est la mer qui prend l'homme ça vous
rappelle quelque chose
vous avez une petite pièce pour lui et
ben je vais pas de porte monnaie pour
moi avec une carte bleue et pontault je
suis très content de vous rencontrer
moi je cherche pas où tu peux lui dire
tu 1 c'est plus qu'une mère maintenant
mais non il y en a on se demande si
j'attends passé ou en étrangers
voulaient bien signer sa pétition contre
le réchauffement de la planète alors au
venir la maison un jour suisse et
beaucoup dormi ça marche pas du tout son
album il allait faire une tournée dans
le métro ou les lignes modèle
autographes les crimes chanson sur ton
temps ça n'a pas marché
dépêche on essaie d'avoir au moins trois
d'autographes aujourd'hui avec dutroux
et vous le faites travailler dur comme
ça tout le temps
s'il reprend les compères et sont trop
il y aurait 50 millions
deux prétendants
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu